yeah we understand now Mark that he was
uh within Downing Street at the time
this uh silver Kia drives into the front
Gates he'd been due to depart number 10
anyway but uh left very soon uh after
the Times newspaper publishing a video
of his armored motorcade leaving the
backstage back Gates of Downing Street
if you look around here A White Hall is
now open to traffic both ways so cars
bicycles coming down the streets
earlier there were police officers with
blue forensic gloves searching through
the boot the boot of this silver
hatchback car and putting some items
into evidence bags that has now stopped
there are no police officers anywhere
close to this silver Kia hatchback and
also the registration plate has been
taken off the back of the car of course
it's a very highly secure part of town a
huge amount of armed police here 24
hours a day mark it seems like they
reacted pretty quickly but the fact that
they are calm the police are calm the
fact The Cordon was reducing now the
whole of the street has been opened
suggests they're they're pretty
confident they know what has happened
even though we do not know quite yet
what has the fact that we also know the
incident is being dealt with by the
local Borough Force by Westminster not
by counter-terrorism please suggest they
don't think this is Terror related we
know that one individual was arrested at
the scene very soon after on suspicion
of criminal damage and of a dangerous
driving no reports at this stage of any
injuries but clearly because of the
nature of this because of this location
at the heart of power outside the prime
minister's home that is why there is so
much media interest so many tourists
who've stopped and so many protesters as
well but but at this stage the
examination of the car seems to have
stopped the police investigation that
seems to be continuing sure we
understand now it's been dealt with by
the local
police not by counter-terrorism command
of Darling Street
yeah okay Joe thank you very much